president Trump dumps his Secretary of
Homeland Security Democrats compete to
shore up their whoa credentials and the
Israeli election is in the homestretch
I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro
show welcome back this is the Ben
Shapiro show guys I'm so excited to be
here this week I mean there's a lot
going on this weekend there's a lot in
the news we'll get to all of it thanks
by the way for people who continue to
buy the right side of history which
continues to soar on the bestseller
charts number three on New York Times
bestseller chart this week in a second
week after being number one in its first
week continues to be at the top of the
Amazon charts as well go pick up a copy
the right side of history we're gonna
get to all the news and just inks
there's a lot of news that is breaking
first let us talk about the fact that
you could be healthier well how could
you be healthier well one of the things
that you could be doing is making sure
that you get your daily dose of vitamins
the stuff that you actually need
vitamins and supplements can be
confusing Persona takes the guesswork
out of it here's how it works you get
three to five-minute assessment to find
out exactly what you need you get
recommendations based on your goals
lifestyle allergies special diets and
prescription medications and then you
get convenient vitamin packets delivered
to your door every single month you can
certainly find cheaper vitamins but
you'd have to pay 30% more to get the
same quality in a bottle of vitamin this
is the best value you can find persona
checks for over 850 medications against
their database of supplements they can
recommend to ensure no negative
interactions they offer over 90
different supplements creating 5
trillion possible combinations to
personalize your recommendation
specifically for you persona is always
updating their questions and
recommendations as new science comes out
they have the knowledge of for doctors
not just one to help them stay
cutting-edge your personalized
supplements are then put into packs
divided by time of day so supplements
that help each other absorb our together
ones that shouldn't be taken together
are for another time of day that also
means your energy supplements can be
taken in the morning your sleep
supplements at bedtime which is pretty
clever right now whether you want to
sleep better have more energy or simply
stay as young as you can my listeners
can go to persona nutrition calm
Shapiro's that's P er s ona nutrition
calm / appear we'll get 50% off your
order today solid deal persona nutrition
calm / appear oh it's 5 minutes that can
change your health persona nutrition
calm
/ spirits really clever and obviously
they're doing a good job on the medical
side - go check them out persona
nutrition calm / apparel get 50% off
your order
his very moments okay so over the
weekend the big breaking news the
Secretary of Homeland Security is out
that'd be Christian Nielsen this had
been coming for quite a while there was
unease with her inside high centers of
the administration and it was sort of
unclear why and I sort of feel bad for
Christian Nielsen because she did the
best that she could with a policy an
administration that is really divided on
immigration President Trump wants to be
incredibly harsh on the border but then
every time there's a bad story on the
border
he immediately shied away from the bad
story on the border and that puts people
like Christian Nielsen in a really
difficult position because he'll say to
her okay I want a zero tolerance
approach on the border and she'll say
all right well you know what that means
that means you can arrest people and
under current law that means we then
have to release the kids to family
members because we can't actually keep
the kids in custody under a Ninth
Circuit Court of Appeals ruling we're
just not allowed to do that under the
Flores settlement and to President Trump
be like okay do it so she'll do it and
then there are a bunch of stories about
family separation and then you'll say
you know this is really bad press let's
not do that anymore and then she says
well that really only leaves us with one
option which is catch and release he
says okay do it and then there's catch
and release for a while and then there's
a bunch of blowback from the right
saying why are we just picking these
people up at the border and then
releasing them to the interior and then
Treme's like well i don't like that
either
this is bad we need to be harsher at the
border the problem is that there are two
serious issues at the border one is the
state of the border law there are real
problems of border law in the sense that
right now under the flora settlement if
you arrest a family that is coming
across the border you cannot hold the
kids in custody with the parents and
that means that you have to release the
parents or you have to separate the
parents from the kids that is a problem
that is currently implicit in the law
and that can be changed by Congress
that's something that the president
should be working with Congress to
change either the kids should be kept
with the parents or they should be
immediately deported right those should
it should not be that we have to release
illegal immigrants into the interior of
the country to deal with the fact that
they have kids this is not a solution
for the kids it's not a solution for the
parents it's not a solution for the
country that is problem number one
problem number two is that we do not
have sufficient funding to take care of
all the people crossing the border we
spoke last week with one of the Chiefs
of Border Patrol down in the San Diego
sector on a radio show and he was saying
that they are simply overwhelmed tens of
thousands of people crossing the border
there's no place to put them
Congress is not allocated
funding and that means that they have no
choice but to catch and release well
president Trump is not famous for the
buck stopping at his desk
usually the buck stops at everyone
else's desk it's it's one of the really
negative parts about this White House is
that if you work for Trump there is a
very good shot that you get stabbed in
the back at some point I mean not to put
too fine a point on it but the reality
is working in this White House is a very
difficult job it is an unrewarding job
it is one where the the press will try
to savage you Christian Nielsen's on her
way out now there are already members of
the press saying she should never be
hired again because she worked as
Secretary of Homeland Security under
Donald Trump and any corporation that
hires her is going to be subjected to
the rage of the mainstream media people
were tweeting this out yesterday that
basically her life should be ruined
you've heard them say the same about
people like Sarah Huckabee Sanders that
afters how could be Sanders leaves the
administration at some point or if the
administration comes to an end then she
should be forbidden from working in the
public sector you you see this in the
private sector you see the same thing
with people who used to work for a
president Trump like Sean Spicer once
they are out then they are persona non
grata among the general public and the
media don't want them anywhere near
anything that even remotely approaches
power in the private sector so does
unrewarding to work there because the
president is very likely to blame you
for stuff that he himself is responsible
for because he has no coherent policy
and second when you are ousted then you
know it's not like you get the gratitude
of a nation for having served your
country instead it turns into you serve
that bad guy Trump we're going to make
sure you never work again in this town
so you got to feel a little bit bad for
Christian Nielsen even if you don't like
how she has performed as Secretary of
Homeland Security and again I failed to
see how she has wildly underperformed as
Secretary of Homeland Security like what
she could have done that should have
been done extraordinarily differently
without president Trump's approval the
New York Times reports Christian Nielsen
the homeland security secretary resigned
on Sunday after meeting with President
Trump ending a tumultuous tenure in
charge of the border security agency
that had made her the target of the
president's criticism I've determined
that it is the right time for me to step
aside Nielsen said in a resignation
letter I hope that the next secretary
will have the support of Congress and
the courts in fixing the laws which have
impeded our ability to fully secure
America's borders and which have
contributed to discord in our nation's
discourse Nielsen requested the meeting
to plan a way forward at the border
in part thinking she could have a reason
conversation with Trump about the role
according to three people familiar with
the meeting she came prepared with a
list of things that needed to change to
improve the relationship with the
President Trump in recent weeks had
asked Nielsen to close the ports of
entry along the border and to stop
accepting his asylum seekers which
Nielson found ineffective and
inappropriate and again I'm not sure
that she is wrong about this closing the
ports of entry along the border was
specifically designed presumably to
reshift wreaks resources to allocate
resources from the ports of entry to the
areas between the ports of entry where
ninety percent to people are trying to
to cross but the issue there Nielson was
saying is when people cross the border
the vast majority of them are looking
for Border Patrol agents to turn
themselves into so that they can claim
asylum so stop accepting asylum seekers
means that you will actually be
encouraging people to avoid Border
Patrol agents and they will simply
continue crossing because there's a
shortage of the border and they won't
turn themselves in to Border Patrol
agents which means no ankle monitors no
keeping track of them and if you close
the ports of entry it is difficult to do
that and still maintain open Commerce
you could do it theoretically but
practically speaking apparently this is
quite difficult
well the 30-minute meeting was cordial
Trump was determined to ask for her
resignation after the meeting she
submitted it the move came just two days
after Trump was repeatedly expressed
anger and a rise in migrants at the
southern border withdrew his nominee to
run immigrations and Customs Enforcement
because he wanted the agency to go in a
tougher direction Trump has ratcheted up
his anti-immigration message in recent
months as he seeks to galvanize
supporters before the 2020 election
shutting down the government and then
declaring a national emergency to secure
funding to build a border wall cutting
aid to Central American countries and
repeatedly denouncing what he believes
is a crisis of migrants trying to enter
the country he tweeted on Sunday night
after Nielson departed he tweeted quote
our country is full which was in fact a
different message than the message that
he was saying in February where he
suggested that we wanted to have wide
doors for immigration where there's
gonna be a big wall with big doors is
the way that he put it Nielson said she
plan to stay on as secretary through
Wednesday in order to assist with an
orderly transition the abruptness was
unusual because DHS does not have a
deputy secretary who would normally take
the reins the president said in a tweet
that Kevin McHale Enon the commissioner
of Customs and Border Protection would
take over as Acting replacement for
Nielson by law the Undersecretary of
management Claire Grady is next in line
to be acting secretary the White House
would have to fire her to make mr.
mikulina an acting secretary people
familiar with the transition said Grady
says that she has no intention of
resigning some of the people who are
being looked at for DHS include Ken
Cuccinelli the former Virginia Attorney
General who fits the profile
apparently and Nielsen has been
pressured by Trump to be more aggressive
in stemming the influx of migrant
crossings at the border her entire time
in the job was spent battling back
suspicions from the president even as he
told people how he liked how she
performed on television and enjoyed
dealing with her personally apparently
he was skeptical of her because she had
served under W and also because she was
close to John Kelly who Trump basically
got rid of that former chief of staff
the president called Nielsen at home
early in the morning to demand that
she's take action to stop migrants from
entering the country including doing
things that were clearly illegal such as
blocking all migrants from seeking
asylum which you cannot do right if
somebody crosses the border and they
find a Border Patrol agent they do have
the legal ability to seek asylum you
can't just say sorry I didn't hear you
sorry guys nope
you know what would you like you can't
really do that to people who are
crossing the border and seeking asylum
nor frankly do we want that because
there are people legitimately seeking
political asylum in the United States is
a long and trench part both our law and
culture that people who are seeking
political asylum should at least be
heard out she repeatedly noted
limitations imposed on her department by
federal laws court settlements and
international obligations apparently
this really pissed off Trump the
president's fury erupted in the spring
of 2018 as Nielson hesitated for weeks
about whether to sign a memo ordering
the routine separation of migrant
children from their families so that the
parents could be detained and again she
was hesitating because Trump was
hesitating if you don't recall it time
it wasn't like Trump was full-scale go
Trump puts his people out there very
often and then he lets them take the
bullet and it's not just Secretary of
Homeland Security he did this to his own
Secretary of Education Betsy DeVos just
in the last couple of weeks we discussed
it on the show he pushed a budget that
included in it a defunding of the
Special Olympics and Betsy DeVos
dutifully did what she was supposed to
do she went out there and she defended
the budget cutting money for the Special
Olympics and then Trump decided on the
spur of the moment he didn't like the
media coverage and he went out publicly
and said you know what we're putting
that back in funding for the Special
Olympics and there is Betsy DeVos left
out there on the end of the branch and
Trump grinning in
off the branch behind her it's very
difficult to work for this president in
a cabinet meeting surrounded by her
peers from castigated her repeatedly
leading her to draft a resignation
letter and to tell colleagues there was
no reason for her to leave the
department any longer by the end of the
week she had reconsidered it and
remained in her position becoming an
increasingly fierce supporter of his
policies including the family
separations and again that's her
reflecting the boss Trump was split and
then Trump said I'm not split anymore
and she said okay well if that's her
policy that's your policy
apparently Trump and Stephen Miller the
president stopped immigration advisor
have privately but regularly complained
about Nielson Lou Dobbs has also
encouraged Trump's negative view of her
handling of the migrant crisis according
to the New York Times Nielsen lost a
powerful protector when John Kelly her
mentor was fired at the beginning of the
year multiple White House officials said
she had grown T plea paranoid in recent
months after numerous stories about her
job being on the line she had also
supported the ice nominee Ronald the Ted
video that Trump just withdrew
apparently in early 2019 is the number
of migrant families from Central
American country surge the president's
fury of MS Nielsen did too he repeatedly
demanded she cut off four and a to
Central American countries though the
funding was the responsibility of the
State Department and she deflected his
demands because she doesn't have the
power to do that one day after Nielsen
traveled to Honduras to sign a regional
compact with officials from Guatemala
Honduras and El Salvador Trump cut State
Department funding for the country's in
recent days the president made public
moves to undercut her Authority leaking
news he might nominate an immigration
czar to assume oversight of the issue
at the heart of Nielsen's Department now
the media is trying to suggest that
Nielson had some sort of real difference
of mind with President Trump it's not
that it's that Trump has a difference of
mind with Trump our Trump is all over
the place on this issue it makes it very
difficult for his people to serve
honorably in his administration it's a
serious problem it is a serious problem
I'll get some more of this in just one
second first warm weather season is
basically here luckily Tommy John the
most comfortable underwear on the planet
has the fabrics you need to stay cool
dry adjustment free they've got so many
new arrivals prints colors patterns
you've got options this summer head on
over to Tommy John calm for all of their
life-changing products both Tommy John's
men's and women's underwear support and
no wedgie guarantee comfortable stay put
waistbands a range of fabrics that are
luxuriously soft designs move with you
not against you not only this time you
try and have ridiculously soft
loungewear for around the house but they
have all new
insanely soft second skin polo shirts
reinventing casual comfort for guys who
want to feel as great as they look in
for ladies they've got the new air
collection it's made from lightweight
breathable fabric with seamlessly bonded
edges Tommy John is so sure you're gonna
love the fit and feel it's all backed by
their best pair you'll ever wear or it's
free guarantee that means if you don't
love that first pair you get a full
refund Tommy John no adjustment needed
hurry on over to Tommy John comm slash
man right now to get 20% off your first
order that is Tommy John comm slash gun
for 20% off Tommy John comm slash Ben go
check them out it's not just their
underwear that are fantastic they've got
all this other clothing for summer that
is just as great go check them out right
now Tommy John comm slash men get 20%
off your first order when you do ok so
as I say a lot of the president's
defenders are gonna say that Christian
Nielsen was doing something deeply wrong
here he appointed her this is the same
sort of shtick we saw with former
attorney General Jeff Sessions Trump
appointed Jeff Sessions one of the
reasons he appointed Jeff Sessions is
because Jeff Sessions was tough on crime
he was tough on drugs he was tough on
illegal immigration and then Trump
decided he didn't like him and then
instead of capping him
he kept him around for a couple of years
and then he let sessions quietly sort of
resigned sort of quit sort of be fired
you see that with this president he does
this all the time he goes after his own
subordinates well when you are the
leader of a company or a country when
you're the leader of an administration
which effectively is just a company the
buck stops with you that means you have
to make the decisions about whether
people are doing their jobs or not and
if you are randomly shifting if you're
driving if you're careening all over the
road like beta O'Rourke on an off night
then it's gonna be very difficult for
the people in the back of the car to
take credit for what exactly is going on
Trump's the guy with his hand on the
steering wheel not Christian Nielsen so
if you don't like the policy that one
stops at the top
apparently Nielsen never learned how to
manage Trump people familiar with our
discussion said he often felt lectured
to by Miss Nielsen which again is
difficult because the president hates
the president doesn't know things oh he
doesn't he just has gut instincts and
sometimes that's okay because people
around him are able to mitigate his
harder edges and they're able to boost
the stuff about him that's good but it
means that he is in constant conflict
with the people around him he's like a
billiard ball just moving around that
table apparently chart Kushner didn't
like Nielsen that came to a head
recently as Kushner had inserted himself
into the immigration discussions now
that's kind of odd
Kushner is not a hardliner when it comes
to immigration Kushner is much softer on
illegal immigration
remember Kushner is also the guy behind
the first-step Act so the fact is that
if you really believe that Nielsen was
ousted for being too soft on immigration
what does Kushner have to do with
anything Trump often blamed Nielsen for
the surge in migrant crossings but the
truth is that the widespread perception
of her is that she was very harsh on
illegal immigration and that is her that
that's going to be the perception of her
after she leaves so here is her letter
she issued a letter about all of this
upon leaving and here is here's what she
said should mr. president I hereby
resign from the position of secretary of
the US Department of Homeland Security
effective April 7th 2019 it has been my
great honor to lead the men and women of
the department as its sixth secretary I
could not be prouder of and more humbled
by their service dedication and
commitment to keep our country safe from
all threats and hazards I turn all
Americans in thanking them for their
sacrifices and those of their families I
am immensely proud of our successes in
transforming DHS to keep pace with our
enemies and adversaries whether it is in
cyberspace or against emerging threats
from new technologies despite our
progress in reforming homeland security
for a new age I have determined that it
is the right time for me to step aside I
hope the next secretary will have the
full support of Congress in the courts
in fixing the laws which have impeded
our ability to fully secure America's
borders and which have contributed to
discord in our nation's discourse our
country and the men and women of DHS
deserve to have all the tools and
resources they need to execute the
mission entrusted to them I can say with
confidence our homeland is safer today
than when I joined the administration we
have taken unprecedented actions to
protect Americans we've implemented
historic efforts to defend our border
combat illegal immigration obstruct the
inflow of drugs and uphold our laws and
values we've responded decisively to
record-breaking natural disasters and
helped Americans rebuild and she
concludes thank you again for the
privilege to serve the American people
and to lead the outstanding men and
women of the Department of Homeland
Security supporting these Patriots has
been the honor of a lifetime
sincerely Christian Nielsen now as I say
the media are already jumping into you
should never have another job and it's
really disgusting hey Christian Nielsen
has really not done anything here to
earn the ire of the media in this way
she's enforcing the laws on the books
the laws suck this is the problem there
are not the resources the border
necessary and that is partly due to the
media coverage of these issues it was
the media that declared for months
and there was no crisis at the border
then the government shutdown ends and
suddenly there's a crisis at the border
media paid very little attention when
Barack Obama was implementing family
separations and then when Trump did it
suddenly it was Trump's fault when the
reality is it's the Florida settlement
in the ninth circuit's fault all of this
is media malfeasance and Christian
Nielsen has very little to do with this
I think she is a functionary and I think
she was a functionary trying to do the
best that she could and I think the
shoes did because the best that she
could apparently wasn't good enough but
I failed to see where she was impeding
Trump's agenda in any serious way where
Trump said do X and she said I'm not
doing accident so he said okay you're
fired I don't see that at all here I see
a bunch of different statements and
policies coming out of the White House
Trump himself doesn't know beyond sort
of the broad outlines of what he wants
how he wants to implement and he's not
willing to take the hit when the bad
press comes in now again I think this is
aided and abetted by a media that wished
to polarize a debate that really should
not be polarized we should all be on the
same side of this immigration debate we
want to make sure that the people who
are coming here are both treated
humanely and deported if they do not
have a legal claim to be here and that
should be done expeditiously it should
be done forthwith family should not be
separated in that process right I think
we all have the same basic priorities on
all of this but the way the media have
played this has led to the polarization
of an issue which really should not be
polarized
I think there's broad American consensus
that we do not want an open border
that an open border is a bad idea and
despite the more woke members of the
Democratic Party I think even mainstream
Democrats are not interested in in a in
an open border I mean Bernie Sanders is
basically saying this right Bernie
Sanders is believe it or not one of
these saner Democrats on the issue of
the border here's the senator the
socialist senator from Vermont and
current frontrunner for the Democratic
nomination saying you can't have open
borders guys how would you deal with the
social services connected with opening
the borders such as health care medical
and medical care and who do you think is
suggesting opening the border well on
that you're an activist for opening fur
no I'm afraid you me getting your
information wrong there's something with
you okay I apologize thank you
I think what we need is comprehensive
immigration reform that is not simply
you're quite right if you if you're
point as you open the borders my god you
know there's a lot of poverty in this
world and you're gonna people from all
over the world and I don't think that's
something that we can do it this boy
can't do it so that is not my position
ok so again that that is Bernie being
reason but we're all basically on the
same page here but the media have
deliberately gone out of their way to
make sure that we are not on the same
page I will give you an example so
there's a video that went around over
the weekend by some account called mark
mobility I don't know who the hell mark
mobility is he suddenly he put out he
put out a video that he cobbled together
from c-span and then he tweeted out
Donald Trump on people asking for asylum
these aren't people these are animals
this video that was retweeted by him
currently has fifty five point two
million views fifty five point two
million views here is the video that he
put out into the country of trying to
come in we're stopping a lot of them but
we're taking people out of the country
you wouldn't believe how bad these
people these aren't people these are
animals and we're taking him out of the
country at a level and at a rate that's
never happened before okay so that is
the clip that is fifty five point two
million views and it led people like
Pete but a judge the mayor of South Bend
who is getting his kind of current media
bump to tweet out you do not refer to
human beings as animals you just don't
which is weird because legitimately like
two weeks ago
Ilhan Omar referred to President Trump
as an animal but there's something
bigger here and that is that Trump
didn't refer to people seeking asylum
his animals he referred to members of
ms-13 as animals here's the entire clip
threshold
I cannot tell ice about them we have
people coming into the country of trying
to come and we're stopping a lot of them
but we're taking people out of the
country you wouldn't believe how bad
these people are these aren't people
these are animals okay that is exactly
right okay I'm sorry
ms-13 they're their actual motto is what
rape kidnap kill I mean they
legitimately are evil
human beings and this was taken out of
context deliberate to deliberately to
make it look like Trump was dehumanizing
people normal people who are coming
across that border families coming
across the border and the problem is
that Trump then reacts to that sort of
slander by in knee-jerk fashion knocking
off his own officials there is a way for
President Trump to deal with these
accusations there's a way for President
Trump to to weaponize this issue but he
is not doing it properly I'll explain in
just one second first let's talk about
you looking like something out of a
James Bond movie the fact is that you
are wearing an ugly suit okay I hate to
break it to you your suits ugly you need
a better suit how can you get a better
suit well you should have a suit that is
tailored to you you think James Bond
just goes buy something off the rack of
course not he goes to Enzo Chino
probably or he should if you were a real
person living in real life Indo Chino is
the world's most exciting
made-to-measure menswear company they
make suits in shirts to your exact
measurements for an unparalleled fit and
comfort if you're in the middle of
planning a wedding they have tons of
options but for those looking to outfit
their wedding party
I love the wide selection of high
quality fabrics and colors to choose
from not to mention the option to
personalize the details including your
lapel lining pockets buttons you can
write your own monogram on it here's how
it works you can either visit a stylist
at one of their showrooms Indo Chino has
40 showrooms in North America they'll
take your measurements personally I've
done this over in Santa Monica it's a
blast or you can measure at home and
shop online at ENSO Chino comm choose
your fabric inside and out you can
design the customizations and then you
simply submit your measurements with
your choices online and relax while your
suit gets professionally tailored and
mailed to you in a couple of weeks this
week my listeners can get any premium
Indo Chino suit for just 359 bucks at
Indo Chino comm when you enter Shapiro's
at checkout that's 50% off the regular
price from made-to-measure premium suit
plus shipping is free Indo Chino com
promo code Shapiro any premium suit just
359 bucks which is better than off the
rack and free shipping that is an
incredible deal for a premium
made-to-measure suit
once you go custom you don't go back
look better go check out enzo Chino comm
and use that promo code Shapiro's to get
the special deal and let them know that
we sent you alright so how should
President Trump deal with all of this
President Trump should say look we're
all on the same page here we need
changes to the law Democrats are not
providing changes to the law none of us
want people at the border to suffer we
also don't want open immigration give me
the resources I need if you do not give
me the resources that I need I have no
choice
but to implement certain policies such
as we are going to be we are going to be
using the resources that are necessary
to us to hold families together and if
the court and if the court tries to
intervene that's just the way that it's
gonna be judicial supremacy is not a
thing the court does not get to decide
how the executive branch acts this way
we are not going to start catching and
releasing just because the Ninth Circuit
Court of Appeals is unwilling to do this
if you say we have to separate families
then I guess that the Ninth Circuit
Court of Appeals can own that I guess
that we can separate families if we want
old bad by the Ninth Circuit Court of
Appeals decision but we are not going to
do catch-and-release we're just not
going to and don't blame that on me
blame that on the court
blaming out on the Democrats who won't
solve this problem who won't change the
law I'm not going to release millions of
people into the interior of the country
I'm not gonna release tens of thousands
of people into the interior of the
country without knowing where they are
this is not a policy I'm going to pursue
and we are going to ensure I'm going to
go down and I'm going to visit with the
kids of the parents I want to make sure
that they are taken care of I'm gonna go
down there and I'm gonna stand on the
border every day and make this into an
issue
I'm gonna campaign on the fact that
there is a crisis at the southern border
and they won't give us funding but
instead because President Trump doesn't
he's not willing to weather some bad
headlines and then use those bad
headlines as evidence that the Democrats
don't know what they're doing and are
actively obstructing policies that help
the United States instead we end up with
his internecine warfare inside the
administration which again I don't know
what he thinks Kris Kobach is gonna do
if he were suddenly the head of DHS I
don't know what he thinks Stephen Miller
can do that Christian Nielsen couldn't I
guess now they are discussing the
possibility of renewed child separation
policies according to NBC News Trump has
four months urged his administration to
reinstate large-scale separation of
migrant families crossing the border
Trump's outgoing Homeland Security
Secretary Christian Nielsen resisted and
the reason she resisted presumably is
because last time this happened from
turned on his own people and said why
are we doing all of this according to
two of the sources Nielsen told trump
that federal court orders prohibited the
department of secure of Homeland
Security from reinstating the policy and
that he would be reversing his own
executive order from June that ended
family separations which of course is
true so it is confusion inside the
policy that is the problem not
consistency of policy again if the
president's
a consistent policy and his own people
don't follow it and they should go then
they should go
but if he's just all over the place all
he's doing is demonstrating a chaotic
approach to an issue and letting the
Democrats off the hook because this one
really is on the Democrats we could
solve this thing if we changed the law
and provided the funding necessary to
Border Patrol we really could meanwhile
the Democrats continue to get their woke
credentials in order so over the weekend
the Democrat 2020 candidates continued
to push as far left as humanly possible
led by Stacey Abrams so Abrams has not
to Claire I'm not sure whether she
actually intends to or whether she's
just gonna sit out there lobbying for a
VP slot it's pretty amazing for a woman
who legitimately lost a race in Georgia
and her highest office has been the
Georgia House of Representatives to
think so highly of herself that she
thinks she can run for president and win
but who the hell knows maybe she can now
she is out there in public saying on
MSNBC that Georgia's abortion law which
protects babies in the womb after a
heartbeat is detected she's saying that
abortion law is evil that's how extreme
the Democrats are on these issues I
think Georgia has to realize that while
we are enjoying an extraordinary boom in
the film industry there's nothing that
says it has to stay here and we have to
be a state that is not only friendly to
business we've got to be friendly to the
women who work in these businesses you
should not have to worry about your
ability to control your bodily autonomy
because of the governor has pushed such
an abominable and evil bill that is so
restrictive it's not only bad for
morality and our humanity it's bad for
business it's bad for morality and I'm
sure it's bad for Planned Parenthood's
business this is how extreme Democrats
are in the issue of abortion abortion
until point of birth and if you pass a
bill trying to protect babies after a
heartbeat is detected then this makes
you evil I mean that is a pretty
reversed morality but I guess this is
where the Democratic Party currently is
and then you have Bernie Sanders and
Bernie comes out over the weekend and he
says you know what it shouldn't just be
that if you are a prior criminal and you
have cleared your record then now you
should be able to vote again you've done
your time now you get to vote again
Bernie says felons should be able to
vote while they are in prison while they
are in prison so you murder somebody you
should still be able to vote well you
are in prison you defrauded the
government you embezzled from the
government you should be able to vote
while you're in prison according to
Bernie Sanders we got
two million people in jail in this
country and number of them are in jail
for felonies many states say okay we're
putting you away for a long period of
time you're gonna pay a heavy price for
that but we're also taking away your
right to participate in a Democratic
Society you can't vote any more people
while felonies should be able to vote
and I strongly supported that in my
state what we do is separate you're
paying a price you committed a crime
you're in jail that's bad but you're
still living in American society and you
have a right to vote I believe in that
yes I do
that's insane I'm sorry that's crazy
you're an actual felon and he's saying
while you're in jail you have the right
to vote well you're in jail
um yeah I'm somewhat of a fan of kanji
and ethics yeah III do not know how you
have the categorical imperative applied
here let's assume that everybody who's a
criminal that the criminals got to
decide who would actually be in charge
of the government you think they might
vote to relax so for politicians who
pledge to relax some of the criminal
laws of positions I mean they're now
proposing that we lower the voting age
to 16 and let all the criminals vote I
can't imagine how this will go wrong
guys I think this is all gonna be great
yeah Bernie Sanders that guy's the
frontrunner for the Democratic
nomination it's wild
even the so-called moderates in the
Democratic Party are not in fact
moderates Tim Ryan who is a
congressperson from Ohio from an
extraordinarily blue-collar district he
should be running on the principle that
he's going to be a pragmatist and a
centrist and he's going to be able to
bring everybody together in the name of
blue-collar folks everywhere instead
he's out there mirroring the Bernie
Sanders medicare-for-all routine I've
been a supporter of single-payer but I
think if we can't afford the affordable
care act I did because that was moving
the ball down the field that was
providing more health care for more
people making it more affordable see
what week I'm sorry youyou want both
options how does that work well when
you're sitting there negotiating I can't
negotiate with you right now with the
House and the Senate and the White House
but I want more people to have more
affordable coverage I want there to be
some kind of public option where
middle-class people who work hard and
pay by the rules can get some help so
they're not getting squeezed by the
pharmaceutical
companies in the healthcare companies
that's what I want em Ryan is now openly
admitting it I'm old enough to remember
when the proponents of Obamacare said no
this isn't the first step toward
nationalized health care and we were
like yeah you guys were lying well it
turns out they were lying another sort
of admitting that they were lying now I
will say that the the worst statement of
the weekend was not even made by Bernie
Sanders who says felons should be able
to vote while they are in prison or
Stacey Abrams who says that abortion
laws that protects the unborn are evil
the worst statement of the weekend in
its own way was Pete Bell judge the the
mayor of South Bend who I've found to be
an interesting candidate with
interesting ideas we've invited him on
the Sunday special he initially
expressed interest and then he started
to gain in the polls and now it's like
well I won't touch people across the
aisle with a ten-foot pole in any case I
have to show you what people to judge
said because it is a polarizing
statement that I think will be largely
ignored we'll get to that in just a
second first you have to go over to
Daley wire calm and subscribe when you
subscribe you get so many goodies I mean
we work our fingers to the bone over
here for you our subscribers for $9.99 a
month you get not only the rest of the
show live you also get an additional two
hours of the show every single afternoon
yet to ask us questions not only in the
mailbag but sometimes during the show we
take live questions during the breaks
also you get our Sunday special on
Saturday so you could have seen our
fantastic Sunday special with Andrew
yang 20/20 Democratic candidate you
could have seen that on Saturday and
seen the material behind the paywall I
mean there's all sorts of great stuff
that happens when you subscribe and for
$99 a year you also get this the very
greatest and beverage vessels look at it
that leftist year's hot or cold tumbler
feel the power course through you when
you actually hold the leftist here's hot
or cold tumblr anyone who has one can
tell you how wonderful it is how it is
their most prized possession how some
have traded their their kidneys for this
sort of thing well you don't have to all
you have to do is pay $99 a year which
is cheaper than the monthly subscription
and go check that out right now
with all sorts of great stuff that is
coming for you to like additional
benefits for subscribers that we are
working I can't tell them tell you about
them yet I can't tell you they are
awesome all of that is coming soon so go
subscribe also go check us out at
YouTube go check this out at iTunes make
sure that you download our Sunday
specials cuz those are really really
good and we have some great ones that
are coming up in the very near future so
go check all that stuff out we are the
largest fastest-growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
well as with immigration there's there's
a tendency right now in politics to
generate false false polarization that
doesn't really exist based on
castigation of people's character so
president Trump is obviously an evil man
because he wants to shut down the border
this is the perspective of the left that
he doesn't want any legal immigration
this means he's mean and cruel and
terrible whereas Barack Obama was
wonderful and open-minded when he was
keeping kids in cages as folks on the
left like to say about President Trump
well Pete but a judge has been a some a
more attractive candidate then a lot of
the Democratic candidates specifically
because he hasn't done this because he
has suggested the people in the middle
of the country who don't buy into the
far-left agenda may not be monsters
because he has said yeah you know what I
disagree with the founder of chick-fil-a
and I'll still eat their chicken and
that was like the most sane thing anyone
has said in this entire presidential
election cycle well he basically threw
that over yesterday he was talking about
evangelical Christians and he said any
evangelical Christian who votes for
Trump is violating their religion which
is somewhat rich coming from a guy who
believes in abortion until point of
birth right this is somebody who
believes in the idea that man and ISM is
not a man and a woman is not a woman he
believes in the in the sort of
transgender rights agenda who but a
judge is not exactly famous
for believing in traditional
judeo-christian moral standards when it
comes to things like abortion here he
was talking about his own life and after
castigating evangelicals as being bad
Christians which he's been doing the
last couple of weeks he then suggests
that evangelicals have an outsized
hatred of body judge because he's gay
which is absurd I've seen none of this
from the right like legitimately none
but here he is going after Mike Pence
and attributing motives to Mike Pence
that do not exist I want to talk about
this for a second because I think it's
important I would have done anything to
not be gay if you had offered me a pill
to make me straight I would have
swallowed it before you had time to give
me a sip of water thank God there was no
pill thing I wish the Mike Pence's of
the world would understand if you got a
problem with Who I am
your problem is not with me your quarrel
sir is with my Creator okay so this is
just it's such a way to malign Mike
Pence Mike Pence has been dealing with
gay people like his entire career this
idea that Mike Pence sits around at
night and thinks about the bad
where are you getting this legitimately
where are you getting this and it's
always confusing to me
when purportedly religious people and
especially secular people somehow put it
on religious people that religious
people sit around all the time
fulminating about the gays that's not
the case that's simply not the case the
argument that a judge is making there by
the way is an irreligious argument the
argument that he is making in there is
because he has a biological drive to be
gay which is something that I fully
accept by the way that the the that
homosexual orientation is largely if not
entirely genetic I'm totally fine with
that idea I don't think that the science
proves that it's entirely genetic it is
a combination of environmental factors
and biological factors twin studies tend
to show that if one identical twin is
gay only about 50% of the time is the
other twin gay which suggests that there
is a genetic component but it is not
entirely genetic in all cases there's
probably a spectrum that's fine doesn't
matter from a religious perspective the
religious perspective on homosexual
activity is the same as the religious
perspective on adulterous activity the
religious perspective on premarital
sexual activity the perspective is that
you have a biological drive to do X does
not mean that you can do X in a moral
non sinn full sense that is not a
judgment of people but a judge that has
nothing to do with people I don't judge
as a human being and the argument that
if I think that homosexual activity is a
sin that somehow I am anti God is such a
bizarre argument like people have
natural drives to do all those things
all the time like every man has an
evolutionary biological Drive every
straight man has an evolutionary
biological drive to impregnate as many
women as possible if I say I don't want
you to impregnate as many women as
possible might now anti God because God
also made that drive that's a bizarre
argument but the more bizarre argument
is the one that first that by the judge
is making which is that Mike Pence is
sitting around thinking about him I
guarantee you by the judge spends more
time thinking about what Mike Pence
thinks about buddy judge and Mike Pence
spends time thinking about by the judge
this is one of the weirder things in our
modern American politics
it was interesting as hunter Rogen's
show the other day and Joe and I are
friends and Joe was Joe and I were
talking about same-sex marriage and I
said I'm libertarian on this issue I
don't think that the government should
be involved at all on same-sex marriage
I don't think the government should be
involved in marriage at all period I'm a
religion
person my religious marriage matters to
me I don't care what the state's
standard of marriage is because frankly
who the hell is the state to legitimize
my marriage or not legitimize my
marriage I don't care I think that the
state should be irrelevant in this which
would put me on the same page in terms
of policy as most people on the Left
when it comes to same-sex marriage I
don't think the state should be involved
in this stuff and then Joe started
asking about my moral views on
homosexual activities so I told him and
all I could think of
during the interview was why does anyone
care like if you care about my moral
view I'm happy to tell you about my
moral view but why is it relevant to
your life I'm not telling about a judge
what he can and cannot do I'm not saying
the government should do anything to
bite a judge and the same thing is true
of pence you think pence is never met a
gay guy but the left needs to castigate
people with whom it disagrees as morally
inferior as bad as ungodly I've never
heard my pence say one word about Pete
but a judge or suggest that Pete but a
judge is ungodly or unchristian and
that's exactly what I've heard from
people at a judge about a bunch of
people on the right who happened to be
Christian about people who happen to be
religious and disagree with him about
the sinfulness or non sinfulness of
particular activity it seems to me that
but a judge and a lot of folks on the
Left are a lot more judgmental about
religious people than religious people
are even judge are judgmental about sin
especially because religious people all
know that we all sin we all know that
and we understand that that sin does not
mean that the person who sins is a bad
person I sin all the time so do you so
does everybody else but the idea of
using my religious views of sin as a way
to polarize you from me as though I'm
sitting in judgment on you all the time
it's such a deliberate miss Reid of what
it means to be a religious human being
all that can be attributed to his
ignorance or malice that's really all
that they can I have no other answer
meanwhile there was something that
happened over the weekend that I thought
was quite interesting we'll get to the
Israeli election in just a second cuz I
think that that is happening today it's
it's quite fascinating but I want to
discuss a comment made by Barack Obama
abroad so Barack Obama has kind of been
disowned by the Democratic Party to a
certain extent it's the dirty little
secret of the Democratic Party is that
they saw Obama as too conciliatory they
saw Obama is too incremental a lot of
Democrats and so now they're trying to
disconnect from the Obama era which is
why you are seeing these socialists left
rip into Joe Biden that's the dirty
little secret as to what has happened
and the reason that is happening is
because the far left is recognizing
something that many on the mainstream
left are not recognizing and that is
that there is a hole at the heart of
Western civilization the far left is
trying to fill it with socialism and
political rage the right is I think
trying to do the correct thing and
rebuild social fabric in response to
this hole in the heart Barack Obama
doesn't even seem to acknowledge that
hole exists
here's Barack Obama talking about Europe
in 2019 Europe in 2019 in some ways has
achieved the pinnacle of human wellbeing
collectively in Europe right now on
average you probably see the highest
standards of living of any group of
people in the history of the planet okay
and that is absolutely true the question
is then why is Europe falling prey to
complete political polarization why are
they falling prey to right-wing
governments being elected in some cases
more authoritarian leaning governments
being elected in Europe why is all of
this happening why are protests
springing up and Barack Obama has no
answer for this because according to
Obama this should be utopia now the
answer on the right is because there's a
spiritual hole that government cannot
fill the answer on the left is because
you need more government but this is the
reason why Barack Obama is being left
behind it's the reason why the left is
seeking additional polarization as I've
said before in the pursuit of utopia
everybody is either a tool or an
obstacle Obama used to be a tool now
he's an obstacle everybody on the right
is an obstacle rather than a tool okay
meanwhile the Israeli election is
supposed to be taking place right now
basically and Israelis are getting ready
to go to the polls on Tuesday so that
means that they are I believe ten hours
ahead of us we are on the west coast of
the United States that means there are
ten hours ahead of us or tomorrow
morning and late afternoon our time the
polls open and it'll be interesting to
see what happens so I haven't covered
the Israeli election elections I don't
tend to cover foreign elections very
much because we're Americans oh there's
that but it has become a hot button
issue in the United States because the
left has decided that they must be
involved in this election now it is
fascinating to me the same folks on the
web
who are fighting mad rightly so about
the Russians getting involved the
Russian government getting involved in
the American election didn't seem to
mind very much when Barack Obama
deliberately involved himself in the
Israeli elections he legitimately did
this he like deployed his own people
over to Israel to try and knock off
Benjamin Netanyahu who ironically ended
up out living him politically speaking
and Netanyahu has been in office for
well over a decade at this point he's
the I believe he's about to become the
longest-serving Israeli prime minister
in history and he has gains in the polls
in recent weeks basically there were two
main parties in Israel one it has been
called the blue and white party and it's
it's essentially a unity party between a
center-right party and kind of a
centrist party and the other is Likud
and the way that the Israeli
parliamentary system works is you then
have to cobble together a majority of
the delegates in Knesset in order to
formulate a government say there are
hundred twenty members of Knesset you
need 61 members none of these parties
ever gets close to 60 the biggest
parties will have something on the order
of 30 or 35 seats in Knesset that's what
Likud I believe has now and then there
are a bunch of separate parties who join
up in a coalition government so every
government is a coalition government and
they are deciding about Benjamin
Netanyahu he's been hit with a wave of
bad press there were a couple of
prosecutions that were there were
initiated against Netanyahu in my
opinion these were specious prosecutions
from what I saw and our radio show we
had Alan Dershowitz to discuss them they
seemed essentially like political hit
jobs to me and now you're saying the
American left fighting man they're
trying to get rid of Netanyahu now you
wonder why exactly is the American Left
so upset with Netanyahu and if they know
who hasn't done anything particularly
crazy right Netanyahu has defended his
cut in fact he's acted with I think far
too much restraint with with regard to
Hamas in the Gaza Strip which is
consistently firing missiles into the
center of Israel or at least rockets
into the center of Israel building
terror tunnels shooting its own citizens
and Netanyahu has basically allowed that
government to continue operating if the
if the Israelis want to end that
government they could do it legitimately
any day but the left is fighting Madden
Netanyahu why because they want a more
conciliatory Israeli government now what
the left in the United States does not
understand is that when it comes to the
Palestinians there is no more
conciliatory government the the
government of a blue and white party led
by Gon's and Lapine the pentagon said
for
general in the in the IDF and and Yair
Lapid is the son of a far left guy who's
now a more moderate he was an anchor on
television for a while and they formed
this unity party on foreign policy
they're not gonna be any different than
in yahoo has been the only thing that
might be a little different is you won't
see them cozy up quite as much to trump
but they are not going to suddenly start
cutting deals with the terrorists
governments in the gaza strip or the
terrorists government in judea and
samaria nonetheless you're seeing far
leftists like beta O'Rourke
who by the way is so far left that he
voted against the funding of Israel's
Iron Dome right the the very system that
allows Israel to shoot down rockets that
are flying over Tel Aviv beta will work
voted against funding because he's a
full-on Obama bro when it comes to
Israel
here's beta or were calling Netanyahu a
racist be why because bit cuz this
skateboarding doofus thinks that he
knows anything about Israeli politics
the us-israel relationship is one of the
most important relationships that we
have on the planet and that relationship
if it is to be successful must transcend
partisanship in the United States and it
must be able to transcend a prime
minister who is racist as he warns about
Arabs coming to the polls who wants to
defy any prospect for peace as he
threatens to annex the West Bank and who
has sided with a far-right racist party
in order to maintain his hold on power
now I don't think that Benjamin
Netanyahu represents the true will of
the Israeli people okay I love this crap
from bata O'Rourke Netanyahu doesn't
represent the true will of the Israeli
people he's been elected a bunch of
times they have a democracy over there
so don't tell me he doesn't represent
the true will you know doesn't represent
the true will of Texans beta O'Rourke
who no longer holds in office so there's
that what a bunch of crap also by the
way when Netanyahu was talking about
Arabs coming to the polls he was
specifically talking about Arab parties
which in Israel have called for the
explicit end of Israel as a Jewish state
so there's that but it is it is amazing
you know the the fact that the left is
perfectly willing to involve itself in
Israeli elections in a way that the
American right does not is pretty
telling is pretty telling
now listen so I think that's now who I
think it's in Yahoo is a terrific prime
minister I think overall he's done an
excellent job in Israel if I were an
Israeli citizen and if I voted in Israel
then maybe then I would probably vote
for Netanyahu over
Johnson l'épée just cuz I don't know
anything about constantly peed and I
don't think that they have themselves
decided what their platform is but I'm
an American citizen and that means that
and I care about America because this is
my country Israel is not my country so
that means that maybe the Israelis
should decide for themselves whom best
to elect not bado frickin O'Rourke a guy
whose knowledge of the Middle East is
about the same as his knowledge of
legitimately any issue which is to say
near minimal okay time for some things I
like and then some things that I hate so
things that I like over the weekend I
was able to take my wife to a movie yes
I know it's like this is these are these
small victories you win when you have
small children and your wife is
finishing up a residency we went we saw
Shazam and the movies just delightful
it really is delightful it's I think as
you know I am a DC / Marvel guy
I think DC is better than Marvel I think
that these most of the DC movies that
everybody hates are better than most of
the Marvel movies that everybody loves I
will continue to defend despite all of
the detractors Batman V Superman I will
continue to defend that no one can
defend Justice League no rational human
being can defend Justice League but I
will continue to defend Batman V
Superman Shazam is just wonderful it has
one of the best comedic sequences in any
of these comic-book movies ever
but it's clever and it's a movie with a
heart Zack Levi is a real movie star man
he's terrific in this film and it's it's
just great the one who's really terrific
is one of the kids not the kid who plays
Billy Batson for those who don't know
the Shazam story basically it's it's
this ridiculous premise been around
since I think the 40s in which a kid
basically turns into Superman every time
he says the word Shazam is Billy Batson
and so it's basically the movie big
right the kid is like a 14 year old who
suddenly inhabiting the body of the
superhero here's a little bit of the
trailer you've run from foster homes in
six counties
I can take care of myself when you're 18
give these people a chance because
that's what they're giving you
[Music]
this is billy batson make sure you make
him feel at home
they seem nice but don't buy it it gets
real gameofthrones around here dude just
mess around you and you're like why so
dark you're disabled foster kid you've
got it all that kid is the best thing in
the movie and the movie really is it
really is fun it's it's and they're
they're a bunch of kind of tie-ins to
the rest of the DC Universe it's great
yeah I think you'll really enjoy it red
letter media has a really good take on
it as well so go check that out too
okay other things that I like so in
Hollywood if you're even remotely
right-wing there's a good chance that
you get excised Rob Lowe has said some
things that are obviously quasi
conservative he made a joke about
Elizabeth Warren which are not allowed
to do if you're in Hollywood also he
made the mistake of mocking the avocado
shortage saying like it's okay
Millennials you're certain you'll
survive and now people are mad at him
but he is correct he is correct here's
Rob Lowe making fun of the avocado it's
really funny I'm sure he'll get a bunch
of crap for it because we're not allowed
to make fun of the hipsters or the or
the Millennials who are so incredibly
woke but don't understand how privileged
they are okay time for some quick things
that I hate so the thing that I hate
number one again the media coverage with
regard to this Israeli election is
ridiculous because again the media in
the United States particularly the New
York Times the New Times is legitimately
an anti-israel newspaper and they have
been for a very very long time they ran
an entire 11 thousand were piece by an
active anti-israel advocate in the pay
of Qatar a country that stands behind
Hamas and they didn't reveal the guy's
preferences I mean it's it's like you
get the guy works for a 501c3 that Qatar
has donated enormous sums of money to we
talked about it a little bit a couple of
weeks ago but now the New York Times is
trying to manipulate against Netanyahu
by suggesting the Netanyahu is
supporting annexation isn't an attorney
who's supporting annexation of Judea and
Samaria
know what he has talked about is
applying sovereignty sovereignty over
Jewish areas of Judea and Samaria that
is that is simply an a reality on the
ground that is what is going to happen
whether you have a left government a
right government or a central government
if anybody thinks that's Efrat is
suddenly going to be in a Palestinian
state it's absolute nonsense
every single Prime Minister including a
hood Barak including a coal mayor has
talked about the major Israeli
settlements being part of Israeli
territory because this is the dirty
little secret Israel one-fifth of its
citizens are Muslim there will be zero
Jews living in a Palestinian state
because it will be in fact you want to
talk about a racist apartheid state that
will be the Palestinian state because it
is right now a racist apartheid state in
which they teach their kids about the
murder of Jews on a regular basis
it's truly astonishing the media
continue to claim that it's all about
Israelis greater territorial ambitions
Netanyahu you will recall in the late
nineties signed the Wye River Accords
which get which gave control of a
significant chunk of the of Judea and
Samaria to the Palestinian Authority the
Palestinian Authority then used that
chunk of territory to launch the Second
Intifada in the early part of the 2000s
when he taught when it's now he talks
about annexing Jewish territory areas
who wished their Jewish settlements that
has been part of the deal for a very
long time and as far as just annexing
part or all of Judea and Samaria if you
annex it and then you allow self-rule in
parts of Judea and Samaria for
Palestinians that is no different than
what the United States effectively does
with Puerto Rico in the United States
you if you're a Puerto Rican citizen
you're American but you do not vote in
America's national elections you have
self-rule this is not unprecedented in
any way if the New York Times is trying
to to proclaim that the better solution
is presumably to the continuation of a
terror group in control of all of its
own borders that hasn't worked out badly
anywhere in the world obviously hey
other things that I hate so Kim Fox the
the state's attorney over in in Chicago
who's now under fire for having led
Chelsea Smollett off the hook she
appeared a Rainbow PUSH coalition event
with Jesse Jackson who legitimately is
one of the worst people of the last half
of the 20th century and and there she
proclaimed that the reason she's being
criticized is wait for it because
everybody's racist efforts that I've had
on criminal justice reform that were
once celebrated by many
this county that are now being attacked
because of one case in one celebrity I
think we have to ask ourselves what is
this really about that when we get in
these positions to somehow goals polls
change somehow when you do the best and
that you put our office on national
standards there are people watching what
we're doing in Cook County around
criminal justice reform and yet and yet
ok she's full of it the reason people
are upset is because she obviously led
someone off for political reasons and
who's racist here the head of the
Chicago PD Eddie Johnson the head of the
Chicago PD the superintendent black guy
he's racist or maybe it's the new mayor
who's a black lesbian who's also saying
that this is a bunch of crap it's all
about racism what wouldn't all-purpose
excuse that has become just absurd there
are times when there is something
happening that is racist this is not one
of those times okay final thing that I
hate so there is this journalistic
critic named David Zurich and he issued
what I thought was one of the dumbest
critiques of the Trump administration in
recent history on CNN he suggested that
what fascists do is exhaust the media so
Trump is a fascist oh yeah here does he
likes to be transgressive because he
knows he can drive the Civic
conversation when he does it we have to
report it the other thing Ryan is he
drives us to exhaustion if we quit
fact-checking him if we accept this he
wins that's the way dictators win they
drive the Free Press almost to
exhaustion with this um no that's that's
not how dictators win dictators win by
jailing their opponents and killing
their opponents in doing what for
example air21 or Putin have done that
that's what dictators do how about read
a book you don't this hole Trump is
Hitler routine you can just like Trump
Trump ain't Hitler
you can call Trump whatever you want he
ain't a dictator I mean the guy can
barely tie his own shoes inside his
administration this is this is silliness
but again I guess that if you want to go
this much overboard you can you just
look like a fool doing this okay we'll
be back here a little bit later today
with two additional hours plus if you
want to watch something a little bit
later I'm on Dave Rubens show too
because we are generating hours and
hours of content for you folks I also go
pick up a copy of my national bestseller
the right side of history go check that
out right now we will see you here a
little bit later today I'm Ben Shapiro
this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
this is the Ben Shapiro show executive
producer Jeremy boring senior producer
Jonathan hey our supervising producer is
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stephens edited by Adam sy
events audio is mixed by Mike Carmina
hair and makeup is by Joshua alvera
production assistant Nick Sheehan the
Ben Shapiro show is a daily wired
production copyright day Lee Weyer 2019
hey everybody its Andrew Clavin host of
the Andrew Clavin show everything's
going great in America and everyone's
unhappy could it be we're missing our
old friend uncle God and if so why isn't
anyone talking about it I'll be talking
about it on the Andrew Clavin show I'm
Andrew Clavin